hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today I want to talk about
different kinds of bacterial oxygen
preferences really in the broadest sense
bacteria can be classified into two
different categories based on whether or
not they require oxygen there are
Arrow's or aerobic bacteria that require
oxygen for growth and then there are
anaerobes or anaerobic bacteria that do
not require oxygen for growth on the
board I've drawn five test tubes I want
to point out that these test tubes are
filled with culture yeah so this is just
medium that allows bacteria to grow it
contains various nutrients where the
media meets the air there's a high
concentration of oxygen and then at the
bottom of the test tubes there's a very
low concentration of oxygen so here I'm
using Oh two as the molecular symbol or
oxygen if we look more in depth at
different types of oxygen requirements
for bacteria you see that they fall into
five different categories first we'll
talk about obligates arrows
obligate aerobes are bacteria that
require oxygen they need oxygen in order
to generate energy for the cell in order
for it to be healthy and to grow and to
replicate so all the good air robes are
going to grow only in the top portion of
the Culture Media where it meets the air
where we have a high concentration of
oxygen an example of an obligate arrow
would be Mycobacterium tuberculosis of
course this makes sense
Mycobacterium tuberculosis bacteria that
causes tuberculosis in our lungs and
what do you have a lot of in our lungs
oxygen because that's what we breathe
that's an example of an obligate arrows
next we have facultative anaerobes
hackle kane.and.anna robes are
considered anaerobes because they don't
require oxygen they can survive without
it but if they use oxygen they can
generate more energy more efficiently
and grow better that's why we
facultative anaerobes
they are mostly clustered up at the edge
of the culture medium where there's a
high concentration of oxygen but we see
that some of the bacteria are also
growing lower down the to Whistleblower
oxygen concentration because they can
survive these conditions coli is an
example of a patatas in our room we keep
moving on now we get to be obligate
anaerobes
as you might expect from their name they
are anaerobes because they don't require
oxygen and in fact oxygen is toxic to
these kinds of bacteria that's why in a
test tube we see that these oxygen the
bacteria are only growing in the portion
of the test tube where there is no
oxygen present an example of an obligate
anaerobe would be different kinds of
Australian species so for example
Clostridium botulinum which causes
botulism equal 30 of tec-9 which causes
tetanus this makes sense as well because
if you think about when people get
botulism it's often from ingesting food
it was not prepared properly that's been
sealed so it's been in a can where
they're not able to grow and then once
you eat them they enter into this
oxygen-depleted condition where they're
able to germinate in the end grow it's
the same thing with tetanus look if you
get stabbed by a rusty nail those
bacteria are able to penetrate so deeply
into your skin they get into parts of
the tissues that don't have much oxygen
and that's where those obligate
anaerobes are able to grow next we have
a classic bacteria called arrow collar
at down arrows
these are bacteria which by their name
anaerobes
you can see that they don't require
oxygen but they aren't really harmed by
it either that's why in the culture
medium and this test tube
they grow throughout they're able to
grow at the top in the middle and at the
bottom and they do so evenly because
while they don't actually use the oxygen
not toxic to them share an example with
an arrow taller anaerobe are species of
lactobacillus these are bacteria that
live in the human vagina and also in the
gastrointestinal tract our final class
of bacteria are called micro arrow files
Micro arrow files are interesting
because they require oxygen that they
require it at a concentration that is
less than atmospheric levels it means
that the oxygen that is here in the air
at the top of the test tube and that's
in the very top portion of the medium is
too much oxygen for them to be able to
survive they do require some oxygen
which is why they grow in this narrow
band in the middle of the test tube an
example of micro era file is
Campylobacter jejuni 9 which is it can
be an opportunistic human pathogen and
it can be the cause of some foodborne
illnesses so those are the examples of
five different classes of bacteria
classified based on their oxygen
preferences so we just finished talking
about those five different classes of
bacteria in the ways that they require
or don't require oxygen we talked about
how to some of those classes of bacteria
oxygen is toxic right now I want to talk
about why that is
now most organisms including humans when
our cells go through a process called
cellular respiration
this is what the cells use in order to
generate energy they have a byproduct
called a superoxide free radical
superoxide free radicals are very very
reactive because they have this extra
electron because they'll react with so
many things they can really disrupt a
lot of cellular processes
this makes them toxic many organisms
including humans and most bacteria have
enzymes to help deal with these free
radicals one enzymes called superoxide
dismutase you'll also hear it referred
to as I SOT so superoxide dismutase
changes superoxide free radicals into
hydrogen peroxide this means you go from
having superoxide free radicals which
are very toxic having hydrogen peroxide
which is still toxic but less so and
then humans and many types of bacteria
have additional enzymes these are called
catalase and peroxidase
these further breakdown hydrogen
peroxide into water and oxygen so these
are not Thompson and with those five
different classes of bacteria you have
some like strict arrows that require
oxygen and tolerate oxygen very well
they have these enzymes they're able to
take these superoxide free radicals that
are produced with their energy and then
convert them down to products that are
not toxic other types of bacteria for
example these strict anaerobes they
don't have these enzymes so strict
anaerobes when they're in the presence
of oxygen they're building up these
superoxide free radicals which are very
dangerous and harm the cell and kill the
cell then you have other kinds of
bacteria for example the air of
Tolerance anaerobes where they have sod
they have this one enzyme so they can at
least convert the superoxide free
radicals into a less toxic form but then
they lack these additional enzymes that
convert hydrogen peroxide down to be
non-toxic water and oxygen so this is
why some types of bacteria can survive
an oxygen and other types of bacteria
can't